there is lawlessness in the united
states of america right now and it
starts at the top position in the
country it needs to stop and biden needs
to be held accountable for the
lawlessness he himself has caused biden
wants open borders his party wants open
borders it's been reckless
dangerous and deadly not just with the
fentanyl drugs but with people killed in
this region
texas governor greg abbott blasting
biden's border policies as he calls on
attorneys general from across the
country to hold the administration
accountable florida's attorney general
ashley moody was at that briefing with
governor abbott and she joins us now
good morning
great to be with you thank you good to
have you on tell us about the meeting
what was your takeaway
you know it it is imperative that those
of us that have the ability to do
something to hold this administration in
line with federal law
get together discuss how we can do that
and really see the impacts uh right here
where it's happening uh in person you
know many of us have been down here
multiple times i was here with governor
desantis over the summer we started
seeing record uh folks pouring over the
border we were feeling the effects in
florida with drug overdose deaths a
crime and we felt it was important to be
here you know note that the president
still hasn't been here so it's so
important that those of us that can get
together and push back we get here
strategize talk to law enforcement and
plan yeah you mentioned drugs uh he said
yesterday in that meeting the leading
cause of death
of fellow americans ages 18 to 45 is
fentanyl he said not cancer not car x
and not cova look at these numbers
actually uh the amount seized last year
10
586 pounds of fentanyl that is up 132
percent from the year before what kinds
of stories are you hearing from your
constituents in florida or your friends
in florida about this you know i will go
on unrelated events
throughout the state of florida and i
will have parents telling me about
losing a son that was a star athlete and
took a pill that had fentanyl and died
or
folks of young children that take pills
not knowing it has female in it
one pill can kill and we're having to
launch
campaigns to get this message out but so
much of this is preventable you know at
the beginning of the year we saw
ridiculous
acts by this administration like
canceling operations that went after
those here illegally that were sexual
predators and sexual offenders or
telling our sheriffs to release back
into the communities those that had been
traffickers or burglars even though
they're here illegally release them back
into the communities when we know they
will reoffend i sued i pushed back they
changed their policy and will continue
to do that but what we once thought was
just them failing to follow law you know
federal law requires that
obama did it trump did it that you
deport those he'll here illegally
committing crimes but now
now they're going a step beyond they're
building infrastructure and programs
totally outside the law to facilitate
illegal immigration it must be stopped
we will push back and we thank you for
shining a light on this well and now we
know about these secret flights one went
to your state to jacksonville that we
know of there might have been more
ashley thanks for coming on and what you
do
great thank you you're